okay guys so this is the second in rapid
succession just immediate reaction to a
trailer this time I'm doing the new one
for war of the Planet of the Apes now
you're a reminder i'm not putting up the
video itself not even a little miniature
form down the corner or anything because
i don't want to get my channel flagged
on copyright stuff so check out the
trailer yourself first then come back
here to see my thoughts and immediate
reaction this is going to be unedited
the one thing I'm going to say before I
watch this is coming off of having
recently seen the new spider-man
homecoming trailer I am nervous as to
how much plot this thing might reveal I
don't want it to reveal a ton of actual
plot points and specific details and if
I was a smarter person i probably
wouldn't watch it all because I'm going
I'm going to this movie no matter what
and now all this trailer can do is
either dampen my enthusiasm or spoil me
well that's not true a kid could get me
pumped too but I if I was smarter I
wouldn't watch this at all but i am not
that smart i am an idiot so here we go
[Music]
are you gonna make
look like a fish o Caesar you said
you're like oh god he's in tax I got
some soldiers captured free to search
trees on both even I cannot imagine how
hard I fight only to protect things they
got a white-haired road sick it gets
that you would kill it yummy come on
that new ages but it's better when it is
necessary to abandon our humanity
display
[Music]
woody woody harrelson I'm looking
forward to you but I must offered you
peace I shot you mercy because think of
the flowers it pops eventually even
closer that's the law of nature so what
you've done
what is the human sized who we have an
eight traitor ok
mmm
you can save you I'm so sorry I've got
quiet but oh hahaha yes okay um
obviously I was nervous going into that
guy was afraid of how much your specific
plot was gotta be revealed uh very
little and then what I saw was it all
gone Cesar so awesome he is such an
awesome character and andy serkis plays
him so well and he just looked so good
oh oh that gets me pumped that gets me
really excited I mean I've been excited
for this movie since the end of dawn of
Plenty age this gives me every trailer
that they put out for this movie has
been better than the last one and I'm
loving the the feel of just everything
I'm loving this new this new agencies
although almost was I he's got a shaved
head this spindly little guys kind of
Gollum ask I don't know what his deal is
but I'm immediately sucked in by him so
there's a guerilla fighting with the
human normally that's the sort of thing
that might bug me but this was we had
already seen that that clip where there
was a gorilla you know in with the
humans as they were trying to gun
something down and there had been I
think a lot of questions a lot of
speculation around that you know what's
going on there with the situation are
some human siding with the age 20
there's one hate this one girl exciting
with the human why I don't know and I'm
glad I don't know but that's that's cool
successfully it gave tiny nuggets of
here's some stuff that will happen but
no no firm context we know there's a
conflict that's all they need to sell
this so obviously you know Caesar he's
just trying to hunker down and protect
his family something escalates it what
that's going to I don't know I'm happy I
don't know but something escalate
something makes him go on the offensive
and I am ready to see Caesar on the
offensive I am ready for him to just go
in there and wreck shop and just take
woody harrelson apartment all over him
facing him down I came for you all yeah
ok so it doesn't have to be often
anymore with trailers oftentimes I
initial teasers usually
the best shot at getting me pumped and
getting me excited you really trailers
especially second third trailers
something like this is usually all I can
do is either just keep me at the same
level or just a min my enthusiasm
because it give me too much information
or they give me reason to the second
guess my first impressions or whatever
this one o July 14 ah can't come soon
enough this looks really good okay so
that is my thoughts on the work of the
planet of the apes trailer this is the
best trailer I've seen in a little bit
definitely in terms of my personal while
I like I'm excited fortune it gave me
exactly what I wanted to give me new
tiny glimpses not a whole lot of
concrete information this was great this
was awesome and I'm so excited for this
movie so what will the Planet of the
Apes I'm assuming you've seen the
trailer otherwise everything that you
just saw me reacting to you have no idea
what it was in any case whatever your
thoughts were drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter and council geeks give it a
listen to the counsel of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]